bonsoir à tous je suis ravi d'être parmi
vous ce soir de revenir dans ces décors
où j'étais il ya quelques années pour
vous parler d'un sujet que j'ai
découvert alors que j'étais à votre
place
le biomimétisme j'ai toujours été
émerveillé par le vivant
les différentes formes que prend une
fleur au cours du temps par exemple du
bouton qui s'ouvre qui déploie
progressivement ses pétales pour former
une fleurs épanouies et ça m'a
d'ailleurs inspiré pour mon projet
d'arts plastiques du bac
voici un extrait de ce travail à partir
du modèle naturel du coquelicot par
exemple à différents stades de
développement
j'ai reproduit à l'aquarelle ces
changements de forme mais il n'y a pas
seulement les formes qui m'interpelle
dans le vivant
les couleurs aussi du jaune brillant des
pétales de ficaire le bleu iridescent
des fruits de polliat qu'on en sata ou
alors les couleurs métalliques de
certains insectes dans le vivant c'est
la réflexion de la lumière sur ces
surfaces qui produit ses effets lumineux
ainsi la lumière fait naître la couleur
mais d'autres organismes vivants vont
encore plus loin
ils sont capables de créer et de
produire leur propre lumière
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
bioluminescence on la trouve chez les
vers luisants chez des organismes marins
comme cette méduse ou même chez
certaines bactéries est elle produite
elle remplit de nombreux rôles se
camoufler pour un prédateur servir de
leurre pour ce pour capturer une proie
ou alors attirer un partenaire depuis
toujours le vivant fascine interpelle
nourri l'imaginaire des hommes et
alimentent leur créativité
ainsi les plus anciens témoignages
peuvent dater de l'art pariétal avec ses
représentations d'animaux préhistoriques
plus récemment fin 19e l'art nouveau
reprend les motifs végétaux et les
intègre à l' architecture comme ici les
piliers de la sagrada familia à
barcelone
depuis toujours on s'inspire du vivant
pour créer la proche et artistique
mais depuis léonard de vinci qui était à
la fois un grand artiste
ingénieur on peut aussi s'inspirer du
vivant pour innover la proche devient
technique et aujourd'hui on la développe
de manière scientifique s'inspirer du
vivant oui mais pourquoi
laissez moi vous raconter cette anecdote
de ma professeure à nancy c'était à
l'école du génie rural des eaux et des
forêts alors il ya probablement de
nombreux ingénieurs parmi vous dans la
salle qui ont l'habitude de résoudre des
problèmes de répondre à un cahier des
charges
alors laissez-moi vous vous proposez
celui là imaginez vous devez construire
une structure telle que vous mettez plus
de 6 tonnes à 30 mètres d eau du sol au
niveau du sommet ou être capable de
convertir l'énergie lumineuse de monter
des litres d'eau des centaines de litres
d'eau par jour au sommet et sur un
poteau pas plus large que 50 cm de
diamètre et n'aurait certainement
beaucoup d'entre vous qui me dirait
c'est impossible
ça viendra jamais et pourtant ce sont
les arbres quand l'on croise chaque à
chaque balade en forêt
ce sont les prouesses du vivant il y en
a de nombreux exemples et émerveillée
par leurs prouesses
je me suis tourné vers une formation de
biologie pour en apprendre plus sur le
vivant intuitivement je sentais qu'on
pouvait s'en inspirer et en 2013 je
découvre je découvre que cette approche
s'appelle le biomimétisme
je découvre qu'il ya un mot pour en
parler c'est une révélation
si on veut ça on comprend les mécanismes
du vivant on peut s'en inspirer
ainsi vous l'aurez compris le point de
départ de cette démarche du biomimétisme
c'est le vivent donc dans cette école à
agroparistech
j'ai appris sa diversité issus de
l'évolution des espèces
ces différentes échelles du vivant de la
plus petite le gêne à la plus grande
celle des écosystèmes et la place si
particulière de l'homme par rapport à
son environnement
on cherche souvent à contrôler et
maîtriser le vivant et parfois même le
modifier on sélectionne les espèces de
plantes que l'on cultive on améliore les
caractéristiques des animaux que l'on
élève
et cela à les dérives que l'on connaît
perdu diversité pollution dégradation
des écosystèmes
pourtant je suis convaincu qu'il est
possible d'avoir un autre rapport avec
le vivant ne plus seulement chercher ce
que nous pouvons en retirer comme
ressource mais ce que nous pouvons en
apprendre en termes d'enseignement et
c'est là tout le principe du
biomimétisme
mais comment comprendre les mécanismes
du vivant on a souvent besoin d'avoir un
autre regard sur le vivant et ça se sait
possible en croisant les disciplines je
vais vous montrer un exemple prenons un
exemple qui va vous paraît paraître
banale le pamplemousse vous pourriez
m'en dire qu'il est riche en vitamine c
c'est bon pour la santé que c'est un
agrume en tant quel chrono je peux vous
je le connais sous son nom citrus maxima
qui fait partie de la famille des
rutacées il est originaire de malaisie
très adaptée au climat tropical et on
connaît ses différentes variétés
pamplemousse blanc campe le moose rouge
pamplemousse rose est ce le fruit est
présent sur des arbres qu'il faut faire
plus de 15 mètres de haut et il tombe
sur la maturité sans s'abîmer
sinon les graines périrait très
rapidement étant donné que cette plante
vie dans les climats tropicaux et en
tant que ingénieur mécanique
je peux vous en parler d'un point de vue
très différents je peux dire que c'est
la structure de les corses de son fruit
qui est responsable de ces propriétés
elle possède une porosité variable qui
permet aux fruits de ce comprimé
efficacement et d'amortir les chocs
ainsi des fruits qu'ils peuvent faire
plus de 15 kilos et qui tombe de plus de
15 mètres ne s'abîme pas et ne se
n'explosent pas au sol et en tant que
biomimétisme
cela m'inspire pour développer de
nouveaux casques de moto par exemple qui
permettent de mieux amortir les chocs
il ne s'agit pas de se mettre un
pamplemousse sur la tête ou de
développer des casques qui sont jaunes
mais plutôt de s'inspirer de cette
structure interne du pamplemousse pour
développer de nouveaux casques plus
sécurisé qui
permettre de mieux amortir les chocs et
le fil des découvertes pourraient être
poussées beaucoup plus loin sur de
nombreux exemples du vivant à condition
de regarder différemment les objets
biologiques
cette approche interdisciplinaire jeu
les découvertes au sein du réseau
allemand de biomimétisme biocoop à la
rencontre de ceux qui étudient ils
vivent à l'institut de botanique de
brest et ceux qui s'en inspirent à
l'institut technologique de karlsruhe et
g j'ai rejoint l'homologue français le
sait bios pour développer cette approche
ans en france pour créer ces liens entre
la recherche du monde vivant et les
applications possibles les applications
technologiques
parce que ce lien vous comprenez bien
qu'il ait pas facile à faire qui aurait
pensé qu'un pamplemousse permettent de
sauver des vies donc on facilite ce lien
entre les entreprises et les
laboratoires et la recherche seulement
de vivant on développe également la
formation pour intégrer de l'umih métier
dans des cursus par exemple faire du
vivant un nouvel objet d'étude pour des
étudiants mécanique ou en sciences des
matériaux et inversement pour des
étudiants biologistes ingénieurs
agronomes comment leur faire prendre
conscience de leurs connaissances
peuvent être revisitée sous l'angle du
biomimétisme et de son potentiel infini
pour répondre à des grands enjeux dans
le biomimétisme
on peut s'inspirer des formes se
déplacer comme une anguille des
matériaux résisté comme la nar ou des
procédés capter de l'énergie comme une
feuille
aujourd'hui je travaille sur les
matériaux les matériaux sont partout
autour de nous le tissu nous habille
plastique de nos emballages les murs de
cet amphi et sont devenus la prime des
principales un des principaux
contributeurs des grands des grosses
impact écologique
vous connaissez vous avez certainement
tous entendu parler du sixième continent
plastique qui flottent sur l'océan
pacifique
les matériaux du vivant sont également
partout le bois des arbres les plumes
des oiseaux le cuir des animaux et
pourtant leur fabrication dans traîne
aucune pollution à long terme dans
l'écosystème ils sont entièrement
biodégradable
et on peut s'en inspirer cette approche
du biomimétisme se mettre au service de
grands enjeux pollution dégradation des
écosystèmes besoins énergétiques
prenons par exemple ses besoins
énergétiques n'est procédé nos procédés
consomment toujours plus d'énergie pour
fabriquer des matériaux historiquement
nos ancêtres utiliser les matériaux
qu'ils le ramassait directement dans
leur environnement
la pierre le bois des eaux et
progressivement avec la découverte du
feu il ya une révolution dans la science
des matériaux
les hommes sont alors capable de
chauffer les minerais par exemple pour
fabriquer du métal de transformer la
matière pour fabriquer de nouveaux
matériaux et avec la maîtrise de la
température on un chauffe toujours plus
aux mille 1000 degrés pour fabriquer du
fer 1400 pour du verre et plus de 2000
degrés pour nos ordinateurs
mais jusqu'où vous le vivant peut nous
proposer de nouvelles manières de
fabriquer nos matériaux en consommant
moins d'énergie
prenons cet exemple là une dentelle de
verre fabriqué par une éponge marine qui
vit au fond de l'océan
elle produit ce ver dans l'eau dans les
conditions douces de température et à
partir de composés dissous qu'elle
trouve directement sur place
les chercheurs s'en inspire pour
développer de nouvelles manières de
fabriquer du verre ça existe déjà
c'est ce qu'on appelle le grand domaine
de la chimie douce et c'est une
révolution dans la manière de produire
nos matériaux aujourd'hui un autre de
man c'est celui de la question des
déchets on a sans cesse de nouvelles
molécules de synthèse qui bien souvent
ne sont pas biodégradables
le biomimétisme peut nous permettre de
résoudre ce souci là on à disposition
dans l'industrie plus de 80000 matériaux
différents qui répondent à des
propriétés très variés vous les trouvez
dans un catalogue
et si vous avez besoin de matériaux très
rigide
pour faire un mur vous allez choisir un
matériau données d'un et matériaux
souples pour une voile d'un bateau ce
sera des matériaux différents
ou si vous avez besoin de matériaux
légers pour la l'armature d'un avion par
exemple à chaque nouveau besoin les
chimistes et les physiciens créer de
nouveaux matériaux des nouvelles
molécules qui bien souvent ne sont pas
biodégradables qui n'existe pas à l'état
naturel et cela cause les déchets que
l'on connaît le vivant peut nous
enseigner comment en utilisant des
composés naturels présents dans
l'environnement
on peut générer une très grande
diversité de matériaux prenons l'exemple
de la chitine la chitine dans le vivant
c'est un sucre un petit peu comme le
glucose et elle est présente chez ces
organismes là les crustacés des insectes
comme le ce papillon et les champignons
et pourtant ces matériaux la de ces
organismes ont des propriétés
extrêmement différentes
la chitine compose des carapaces de ce
homard qui est extrêmement rigide qui
lui permet de se protéger des prédateurs
aida kittin et à organiser en un
empilement multicouches en forme
d'hélice qui est extrêmement difficile à
percer chez ces papillons la chitine
forme des petits peigne micrométrique
qui permettent aux helvètes extrêmement
légère extrêmement souple et qui est
responsable également de leur couleur
bleue et chez chez les champignons la
chitine constituent les parois de leur
cellule et forment un réseau lâche assez
souple ainsi vous voyez comment à partir
d'une seule molécule de base vous
générez une grande diversité de
matériaux qui sont entièrement
biodégradable ainsi il pond pourrions
nous imaginer un futur on décompose un
mur pour reproduire pour fabriquer un
avion pour fabriquer nos plastique et
que le tout soit fabriqué à partir du
même matériau présent l'état naturel est
entièrement recyclables ainsi pas face à
la crise environnementale actuelle on a
souvent des discours alarmistes
défaitiste pourtant le vivant peut nous
proposer
un ensemble une rue un réservoir infini
de solutions et en plus c'est un modèle
de développement durable
éprouvé par 3 8 milliards d'années
d'évolution avec ses 10 millions
d'espèces le fil des découvertes est
infinie en parlant de fil nous n'avons
même pas évoqué le fil d'araignée dans
les propriétés mécaniques sont
exceptionnels vous imaginez bien que le
potentiel est infini à travers la
diversité des espèces
les propriétés qu'on peut y trouver
ainsi que les différents champs
d'application ainsi je vous invite à
regarder le vivent différemment vous
émerveiller de ses prouesses notamment
au niveau des matériaux est de plus en
plus d'entreprises aujourd'hui de
laboratoire s'impliquent dans cette
démarche
ainsi je vous invite à mam rêvée pour
nous d'un monde meilleur pour demain
merci
[Applaudissements]